law student at one scottish university
who is being probed for defining a woman
as the one with female genitals well
she's been cleared of all allegations
over it
the inquiry into what was viewed as
offensive and discriminatory comments
took
two months but in the end they found no
evidence of wrongdoing
talking to rt the student described the
pressure she faced at the time
i was under tremendous stress and during
the inquiry you know i had my final
exams i had a dissertation to write
i was still trying to be you know a
mother to my children and function
everyday life and i was just panicking
like i was really focused on the exams
and the dissertation but at the same
time i had this
niggling thought in my head you know
what if it's all for nothing i'm not
sure why
my comments provoked the reaction they
did they were mainstream views
and so why it provoked such a reaction i
don't know
i described a biological woman as
somebody that was born with a vagina and
the ability to reproduce
and i said that on a physical scale the
average woman is weaker than the average
man i would say you know a woman's
always going to be a woman
and i think everybody should live their
best life and everybody should be
theirself
the free speech rather than flared up in
a seminar on law
gender and feminism at abertay
university while the students were
discussing transgender issues
seems classmates reported lisa's remarks
to academic chiefs who then launched a
formal investigation
commenting on the case the university
said it's still committed to upholding
freedom of speech on campus
but lisa keough doesn't take that on
trust
i think in university free speech is
very restricted i think if you don't go
along with the
the the majority narrative then
you're sort of you're vilified and
there's a target on your back like there
was with me
i think people just have to open their
minds and people have to allow people to
have their own opinions
i'm fully aware that i don't agree with
everybody's opinions and everybody's not
going to agree with mine but in an
open debate everybody should be entitled
to say what they want i hope
moving forward everything sort of evens
itself out and things kind of you know
go back to what i would consider normal
i
hope that my case will make other people
feel brave enough to air their views
you